大家好，欢迎收听小新地华，这里是我不跑掉。
今天这期节目是新系列的第一期。
最近想要做的这个系列叫做走一步看一步。
我从小就是一个喜欢提前做计划的人。
但是在过了很久以后我才发现，我不太会真的按照计划形式。
可能我只是喜欢写计划，而不是真的相信计划。
我更相信的是身体的直觉，更喜欢走一步看一步，
走到哪儿算哪儿。
嗯，不知道这是不是也是导致了我总是滑倒，总是放生大库的原因。
后来我才慢慢明白，生命里的每一个阶段都有它的困惑还有苦恼。
经常会打得我们错不及防，所以做计划也没有用。
该吃的亏还是得吃，该完成的课题一个都没法落下。
所以我也越来越意识到，搞杂是正常的，搞杂也没关系。
特别是在慢慢长大了之后，我发现，很多我喜欢的人是误，
好像没有一个使真的按照计划长成现在的样子的。
他们也都是随着那一时内刻的心境，还有处境，做出了选择。
然后经过了一些惊喜，经过了一些意外，起起又落落。
终于有一天，出现在了我的面前，以他们最独特的面貌。
想要做这个系列呢，也是因为在这个当下，
不管是身边的人也好，网上观察到的人也好。
大家在做决定的时候，好像都变得日去保守，不愿意去冒险。
你我都想避雷，避开起路，也一直想要走最安全，确定的那一条路。
当提前规划成为了一种政治正确，万事确定成为了一种执着的追求。
那我很好奇，最后又有谁愿意去接住那些，
在尽全力，做好了规划，完美的规划，之后，
却还是在不确定中麻烦的人呢。
所以，这个系列我想要带大家去看看世界上的一些人，
可能他是一个真人，或者是各种作品里面的角色，
也可能是一个空间，一个角落。
回到那个场景里，去看看他们是如何在空窝中摸索，
也看看自我的那份模样，是怎么在无人之小的一步一步中，生长出来的。
或许在其中的某一步里面，你也会认出你自己。
这系列的第一季节目呢，会围绕一个地方展开。
在这个地方，陈吉珍第一次拿着吉他登上了舞台，
当时还没有变成张璇的安普在这里当音控，
也在后处占了一身有焉味。
苏打绿的吴清风也说过，这里是他音乐和演出的故乡，
是每次都会赶开还可以回来的地方。
这个地方呢，就是对于台湾独立音乐的孕育和发展来说，
非常重要的女巫店。
女巫店位于台北市新森南路三段，56向7号，
就在台大附近。
楼上呢，是女书店，比女巫店早开两年，
也是很多人向往的女性文化空间。
为什么要挑这个时间点牢女巫店呢？
首先呢，就是本人最近实在非常沉迷于台南台女啊。
对于他们成长的这个地方，女巫店的故事非常好奇。
而且刚好今年也下逢女巫店创立三十周年，
我觉得是一个很好的时间点，
让我想要去认真的认识一下女巫店，
也回望一下她的这些年。
虽然我去过一次台湾，但其实我没有去过女巫店，
如今好像去的机会也更渺茫了。
所以我对女巫店的了解，全凭刷各种演出的切片，
还有网上的刀听图说，
不过在决定做这些节目的时候，
我本来还以为会发现一些特别神奇的地方，
但是在跳进了女巫店的兔子洞之后，
老实说，我好像没有什么中道的发现。
我觉得厉害的反而是她的每一步都没有剧本，
也正因此每一步都走得很踏实，
直到她迎来了这个三十周年的时刻。
她也让我开始思考，在人的手上没有地图的时候，
怎么靠着自己的直觉，自己的真，
去创造一个，让别人也可以做自己的地方。
关于女巫店的节目一共会分成上下两期，
这一期会主要聚焦于女巫店的空间，还有其中的人，
下一期会聊一聊一拖女巫店成长起来的音乐人。
让我们先回到故事开始的九十年代，
女巫店之所以能够出现，说起来还是一个挺稀里糊涂的故事。
那个时候还是台湾的后解言时代，
解言是什么意思呢？
这指的是当时的政府在1987年正式解除了戒严令，
长达三十八年的军事管制也就此结束了。
这也是台湾逐渐走向民主的重大转折点。
那几十年的戒严刚结束，
其实特别像一个人好像憋了很久很久没说话，
终于得到了一个可以说话可以喘气的机会，
所以在九十年代初期整个社会也纯纯欲动，
大家都在寻找一个表达的出口。
那个时候就慢慢出现了一些地下乐团。
Livehouse也慢慢出现，像是西朗、人狗、蚂蚁，
这些都是为摇管乐迷专门打造的Livehouse。
也因此地下乐团和独立音乐的发展也有了一些不错的土壤。
不过非常有趣的是，女无电的创始人彭玉京。
在一开始和音乐这两个字基本上是不沾边的。
她当时就读于台大的社会系，
因为在毕业之后找不到工作，
她就想说，既然自己那么喜欢吃，那就找机会创业好了。
所以她先是去了烹饪学校，完成了烹备的课程，
然后又找到了一个大饭店，叫做西华饭店，
在那里的点心房成为了一名小学徒，
她就梦想着以后可以开一间属于自己的餐饮店。
就在彭玉京上了两个多月班的时候，
她接到了女书店，也就是后来女无电楼上的那间店，
她接到了这个女书店的店长音音的电话，
还说也不是电话啦，是BB机，那个是非常古早的传呼机。
那音音就说，要是几回。
当时彭玉京也觉得非常奇怪，会有什么要事哦，
所以她也非常紧急的打回去。
后来才知道女书店楼下的花店要搬走了，
音音就让房东不要租给别人，要留给彭玉京去开店，
彭玉京就觉得很搞笑啊，我要开店吗，怎么我都不知道。
但是呢，就在这样的半推半救下，她去看了门面，
她看到这个场地没有柱子，在当时看起来还算特别，
所以她觉得还不错。
非常刚好，家里又有亲戚愿意投资，还有支持。
就这样，她狐狸糊涂地成为了老板。
不过，其实是在那个时候，她也还是没有想过要开一间Livehouse。
女书店成立的另外一个充分必要条件，其实和另外一个人有关系。
这个人呢，叫做阿峰，但这个可不是苏打绿的阿峰哦，
他是独立乐团骨皮肉的成员，
他也适合台湾早期Livehouse文化发展息息相关的一个非常积极的推动者。
阿峰呢，原来是在台大附近，创立了一个他自己的音乐展演空间，叫做Scom.。
这个空间还挺特别的，他和其他允许全翻唱的那种Livehouse不一样。
Scom几乎是最早一批规定，上台的乐团必须演奏一首原创曲目的地方。
那这个理念对于独立乐团的发展当然是非常有意的。
可惜的是，当时的地下乐团演得非常多是摇拐乐曲嘛。
摇拐乐曲的特点呢，就是超高的声贝。
这样的噪音可想而知，引来了居民领理，非常多的同速，还要抗议。
Scom也因此，吃了非常多警察的罚单。
那阿峰呢，不仅把转道的都倒贴，也因此赔掉了一台奔驰。
后来呢，这个Livehouse，自然也是开不下去了。
呃，所以在1996年，阿峰和彭玉京终于相遇了。
关了店的阿峰，找到了彭玉京。
问他能不能说下之前Scom店里面的音乐器材，
也让他们能在这个新的空间里面表演。
那些器材真的非常多，足足有一车呢。
但彭玉京呢，也没有想太多。
他只想着，公共空间的运用其实也有很多种，
也不一定只是要做餐饮，可以更多远一点。
所以当时就让阿峰他们来表演，
也顺便让他们安排还有支援现场表演的音控相关的事情。
于是呢，就有了女巫店的主席。
当时彭玉京也开玩笑说，
这是台湾地下音乐的第一次地上话。
一开始，女巫店是允许了Scom当时偏好的音乐风格，
也就是很阳刚男性的音乐摇滚的表演。
这里也要插入一个冷知识啊，
就是女巫店的屋顶，是那种木头建筑的衡量。
好处是，他不会像水泥墙一样直接反射声音，
造成很多杂音。
而是可以吸收一部分中高频的声音，
但不会太影响低频的声音。
随终何来看呢，女巫店的空间条件，
对于摇滚表演来说非常的合适。
但是慢慢的为了不重蹈Scom当时的负责，
也就是因为噪音吃了很多罚单嘛，
作为老板的彭玉京也细细的思考了一番。
因为女巫店当时也是在台大附近的居民区，
店面还是一楼，店里本来就是空间小小的，
也很难去思考去装什么隔音设备。
即使让Scom原来的人来操守一些音乐表演上面的事宜，
也实在没有办法说把地下乐团的那一整套都复制到这个新开不久，
空间不大的女巫店来，
不然到时候还是会照视罚单，关门大吉。
而且同期也出现了另外一批主大摇滚风格的Livehouse，
像Vibes之类的。
他们整体的风格也是这种扬纲的摇滚的丝红的，
这就让彭玉京开始探索什么才是最适合女巫店的风格。
后来她做了一个决定，包括三点啊。
一，所有的演出都要做Unplugged，也就是不插电。
二，她希望乐手能够拿出自己原创的新作品。
三，表演者以女性为优先。
这里的每一点都还挺有讲究的。
做不插电呢，与其说是一种立场，不如说是因为担心邻居闲炒，
这是一个被现状逼出来的妥协之道。
也是鼓励表演者在这种摇滚的喧嚣之外，
去寻找那种在你和观众是近距离的时候，
你怎么让他去更投入到这个音乐里面的一些技巧还有法门，
让自己的音乐真的变成一处绝。
她希望大家拿出原创作品，
也是因为你不断的去精进自己，
然后做出自己创作的作品。
这也是一种独立音乐人可以不去依赖大型公司的独立姿态，
还有一种能力吧。
这样也才能够在最大程度上展现自己的生活，
自己的观点，由此做出个人的表达。
那最后呢是优先女性表演者，
这一点其实也挺好理解的，
因为当时比较泛滥的独立音乐的风格就是摇滚嘛，
摇滚在本质上其实和男性的确实是更接近的，
不管是重金属，死后，呐喊，
其实都缺乏女性的身体性。
在当时台湾地下乐团的场景里，
女性更多是从观众席去仰望台上表演的对象，
而这些对象通常都是男性啊，
女性并不作为表达的主体，
所以彭玉京希望优先女性发生的权利，
让她们可以唱自己的歌，说自己的故事。
嗯，就这样原来的女无端看起来是被场地限制了表演方式，
还有入场的人数，
不过在彭玉京各种各样的转念影响里面，
这些其实都不必成为限制，
反而可以成为一种可利用的优势。
顺着这样的限制和优势，
发展出不差电的，强调原创的女性空间。
呃，我记得在女无电的某一个logo图里面，
上面就写着几个大字，
给我原创，其余免谈。
想要在女无电演出的音乐人呢，
必须先拿着demo，
到电里面给彭玉京听。
她不会去考虑这个人的知名度，
或者是说话影的程度，
只会用主观的喜欢去判断，
这个人是否适合在女无电表演。
所以她也慢慢筛选掉了一些人，
也慢慢筛选出了，
和女无电的掉性风格都相符合的一批表演者。
在女无电的官网上，
有一个叫做时光隧道的年表。
她记录了1996年以来，
许多乐团和乐手在女无电首次表演的时间，
可以看到在开业的第一年，也就是1996年，
更多还是像四分位古若皮这样的摇滚乐队，
在年底才出现了陈珊妮。
不过，从1997年开始，
就陆陆续续的可以看到很多我们熟悉的女性歌手，
黄晓珍、伊能静、陈其珍、
98年还有巴奈、99年还有雷光夏，
和当时还没有出道的安普。
在当时，
每个月还有一天被称为女巫会，
因为当天只有女性歌手可以演出。
于是，女性创作者们第一次有了属于自己的舞台，
这也让女无电的图让彻底和其他的音乐空间去分开。
一边是阳纲和音浪的，
另外一边是星星、文艺的。
即便如此，彭于晶也没有把女无电，
只局限于是一个音乐空间。
他一开始就把女无电定位成为了一间女生可以玩很晚的店。
这一点从店内的餐饮配置，
还有不知风格也看得出来。
女无电一直以来，自称拥有着一份挑战人类极限最调皮的菜单。
随便说一些饮料的名字好了，
月经冰茶、酒池肉临、纵草莓。
这些举例出来的还都是小尺度的，
还有一些尺度更大的大家可以自己去搜索。
总之，恶心、下柳都是一些他愿意接受的评价。
据说女无电还有一个不成文的规定，
只要你敢脱下身上的内衣，
挂在椅子上，就可以免费获得一杯饮料。
去过女无电的朋友应该有看到，
店里的不少椅子也挂着五颜六色的内衣。
彭玉京开玩笑说，这个是基于卫生的考量，
希望大家更规律地去更换内衣。
不过这样的布置也是为了让大家意识到，
这些东西也出现在公共空间，
并不是什么值得难为情的事情。
还有一些女性限定的活动，
例如做十个服务称就可以全难久折，
也是一种在美女性力量的方式。
除此之外，也可以看到很多女性摇滚乐手的海豹，
还有各种颜色的女性玩偶挂在墙上的，
从天花板上垂下来的。
厕所里也有一些探索女性性高潮的文章。
当然，厕所里也为女生准备了一些卫生钉之类的用品。
在那个时代，女无电这样的布置是非常先锋的，
它其实就是完全贯穿了彭玉京个人意志的体现。
前面有提到，彭玉京毕业与台大的社会学习，
在学生时期，他其实就受到了第三波女性主义思潮的印象。
那个时候，他也参加过一些性别运动，
比如说反对性骚扰的游行等等，
他甚至是跑在前面，冲锋陷阵的那一批人。
看到过一个细节非常可爱，
虽然彭玉京一直以来都是瘦瘦的，个子也不高，
但是在游行的时候，他也没有害怕，
他经常就会喊说，来呀，不怕啊，台大就在立法院附近啦。
之类的来说，他其实不怕麻烦，
但是他就是一直以来非常勇敢的在做个人的政治表达。
后来女巫店呢，作为一个展现空间，
也和从中承担起来的很多女歌手，
同样也非常积极地参与到了平权的运动当中。
其中最有名的应该就是叫安普了吧。
彭玉京之所以把店取名为女巫店，
也是在试图突破女巫一直以来受到的污名还有歧视。
他对于女巫的理解是，在传统社会里面很有本事，
强化直接又特殊，不接荣于社会的女性，
她们非常的厉害。
呃，女巫店的官网上是这么减少的。
她们充满能量，眼光中闪烁的自信，
勇于提出自己的看法，
不为强权地打压，不怕主流的排挤，自信自在地存在着。
所以说，要做一家让女生可以玩的很晚的店，
对于彭玉京来说并不是很轻巧的随口一说，
因为其中需要的那种安全感的分量是非常厚重的。
对于想要捍卫女性在及时到了很晚的时候，
也可以很安心自在地看表演的权利，
这件事情，她也表达了非常认真的决心。
可以说彭玉京活成了什么样，
最后的女巫店也变成了什么样。
我很喜欢女巫店的一点还在于，
她真的没有把自己框得很死，
她所创导的独立精神，指的不仅仅是独立音乐，
她也欢迎各种各样独立的不一付与商业的创作还要表达。
音乐只是其中的一个面向，其中的一种表达方式而已。
比如在1999年，女巫店刚开业不久，
彭玉京的德国丈夫悠悠，
有主持过和诗歌相关的发表活动，
当时是仍如智成，还有夏宇。
夏宇另外一个名字叫李格蒂，也是一个非常有名的词人，
他们都在那里发表过诗歌。
也有人会用一种接近摇滚的充满爆发力的方式把诗歌朗送出来，
这也是一种很有趣的模糊了诗歌还有乐曲之间界限的实践。
在比如女巫店里也有过阿中布袋系的演出，
布袋系是什么呢？
布袋系其实是一种起源于福建之后在台湾全面发展起来的戏剧方式，
它主要就是通过你的手指和手掌来操控末进行表演。
因为布袋系是没有人生的参与的嘛，
它主要依赖的是后场的音乐，他们进行配合。
所以女巫店其实也是一个很合适的地方。
其他的还有比如说舞台剧等等形式。
安普曾经这么形容过女巫店，
他说少数的观众、表演者和店家一起营造了一个不太需要定义的表演氛围。
在这里你不需要去定义舞台是什么。
那彭于晶的想法是，在那个时代也就是后戒年时代，
其实在闷了非常久之后，
这样的空间是很欠缺的，有很多声音想要发出来。
同时他想要做的这个店，
应该也有他自己想要说的话，他的个性、他的表达。
这种个性也就表现在了女巫店自己的经营上。
有一个例子是，在女巫店20周年的时候，
他们办了一个叫做女巫剧的音乐节。
这个音乐节采取的完全就是独立售卖，
不依赖中间售表商的方式。
用今天的话说就是不要中间商占差价。
他们用人工一键一键的把门票寄给观众，
这是一种非常手工的方式。
当时在谈到这个音乐节的时候，
安普说，音乐真正的友善应该是你在外面买不到的服务的手工感。
纯手工的东西就是有他的独特性。
独立的店家反映在票价上的就是独立的运营成本。
这个就是女巫店自己也像独立这个精神卖出的一步。
另外一件事呢，就和女巫店并没有成为一个厂牌有关，
因为它明明有很多资源可以去签约，
或者说它代理更多的音乐人的发行，还有经济嘛。
但是他们选择不做，不管是出于运营，还是资金上的考量。
独立就是他们选择的态度，
因此他们也不去选择厂牌这样的形态，
因为里面就会包含一些契约关系，
需要去处理和思考的含义规则。
这些都是凡女巫店所主张的自由精神的。
所以在这样一点点的思考，还有容纳不同声音的过程中，
女巫店它变成了今天的样子。
不只是独立音乐而是更广泛意义上的独立的精神。
它也引导了各种各样的表演者在不意负于参与条件的情况下，
一步一步探索出自我的样子。
值得一提的是，女巫店对自己的定位一直是Livehouse界的鞋杠。
她一开始是咖啡馆，然后是Livehouse加酒吧，
然后在周四、周五、周六的晚上九点都有表演节目。
观众的入场费是350台币，大概就是75人民币左右。
这个价格也是附送了一杯饮料的。
加上表演的话，应该说是一个相对合理的价格吧。
后来也有了桌油，装不了大钱，但也死不了。
但是呢，在2011年，女巫店也遭遇过一场歇业风波。
这件事情的背景是一家在台中市叫做阿拉的POP，也就是酒吧吧。
出了一场大火，她带走了9个生命。
也让相关部门开始重视起了Livehouse存在已久的法规问题。
当时的相关部门就经常去女巫店去看茶啊，走访啊。
说女巫店在这个位置，她的分区使用和营业项目不符合标准。
因为在当时做女巫店并不是那么合法的。
这些话都让彭于晋压力特别特别的大。
她就想说，既然法律不允许，干，老娘不做总可以了吧。
然后就经过了一番内部的沟通吧。
说要是有一张罚单下来，那女巫店其实就做不下去了，不如就直接歇业好了。
当时这个消息本来只是内部消息啊，但不知怎么的消息一传出，
女巫店的支持者都纷纷去线上一些支持，有人呢就跑到市场信箱去表达她们的意见。
也有人跑到店里面报买商品，这些都突破了彭于晋的想象。
后来相关部门才决定修改条例，增加一项叫做音乐展演空间业的项目，来让Livehouse的业态得以成立。
女巫店这也才挺过了这场歇业风波。
那另外一个危机很好想象，其实就是发生在疫情期间。
因为疫情的防控，现下门店经常有好几个月都不能开业嘛，
其实是在能开业的时候来的人也只是平常的50%-60%左右。
彭于晋也没有着急采调店里的小女巫店员。
这个说起来还得感谢她们从2011年就开始引入的逐游业务。
她们当时做这件事情在台湾算是很早的，也积累了一批忠实的逐游爱好者。
没想到遇上了疫情，现下演出积极可谓。
恰好在疫情期间，逐游就是可以大力发展的场景。
所以呢，凭借了这个市头，她们也把小女巫留了下来，
让她们帮忙做一些逐游相关的业务。
说起来也很有趣啊，本来你平时去女巫店，
消费者玩逐游其实不需要另外付费，
相当于是依赖其他的业务来养活逐游这件事情。
结果在疫情期间，逐游反而成为了第二增长曲线，
因为在一个空间里面大家总有事情得做对吧，
家长要陪小孩，然后情侣之间也可以玩，朋友之间也可以玩。
所以她也拯救了无法全力进行演出业务的女巫店，
撑起了一片天。
听到这里你可能也会觉得，啊，她不是一个音乐圣地吗？
怎么会又是不带戏，又是作游？
这也太杂了吧。
又或者说，从今天的视角看女巫店，
独立音乐舞台，咖啡馆，酒吧，桌游，通通都做，
其实并不稀奇，甚至有点普通。
但这就是有趣的地方啊，也许正是因为当年这样杂的一个定位，
没有过度依靠音乐演出带来的收入，而是依赖多只脚走路，
女巫店才可以顺利的营业至今，
也可以给刚起步的创作者一些能够喘气的创造空间。
我感觉，就像人果然还是要活得杂一点一样，
店也可以尽力的杂一点啊，也许会有意外的收获呢。
那在研究女巫店的过程中，说实话我对女巫店的滤镜只减不增，
因为女巫店会成为台湾读音乐的圣地有非常多的影响因素，
依赖着天时地利人和，我也有看到有一些网友去了女巫店之后的吐槽，
他们说女巫店混乱冷漠傲慢，
所以过去对于这个文艺空间投射的期待就这样一一落空。
我很能理解这种感受，
同时我也觉得对于女巫店来说，这样的反馈可能并不稀奇，
因为彭玉京说女巫店的臭脸在业界就是出了名的。
在现在的服务业越来越卷的当下，
可能确实对比其他更精致的周到的店，
对比起来确实是相形建筑。
我在想，如果有一天我能够有机会去的话，
也许我也会因为种种微妙的感受而觉得期待落空吧。
但是怎么说呢，我在看到歌手巴奈说的一句话之后就稍稍有一点释怀，
甚至会把这个期待降得更低了。
巴奈也是从女巫店承担起来的，
她说女巫店没有把人插别的看待，
比如说你是客人，但你还是个人。
小女巫来工作，她也是个人，她不一定要面带微笑。
这个空间里面没有因为你是消费者就特别伟大，
人也不会因为工作的性质变得比较低。
你有完毕。
可能啊，我是说可能。
拿这两个稍微有点不相关的事情放在一起，
有一些偷换概念的嫌疑。
但是我的观点是，
也许不要去拿时代赋予女巫店的姓名去套在如今她的头上，会比较好。
因为永远会有错位还有对不起预期的那一天。
仔细想想，女巫店好像原来也不是因为她的温暖，她的服务，
她最先被知道和期待的，是她大方的接纳了一个又一个，
当时也选择了女巫店的音乐人，让他们可以做自己。
说出自己的声音，讲出自己的故事，
也在日后他们远航之后，一次又一次的迎接了他们的回航。
关于女巫店的故事，差不多就说到这里。
最后呢，我也还想要念一下，彭玉京在2011年写给女巫店的一封信。
亲爱的女巫店，写完前面六个字，我浑身不对劲。
我好像比较像女樸咖啡店，而不是女巫店的老板。
人家要我写信，我就写。
还装可爱，写给一个根本不具有阅读能力的女巫店。
1995年底，我大学毕业不到半年。
女书店的朋友说，楼下的店面空了。
我一直为了想开店，到处打工，而学做点心，就在家人的支持下，决定开店。
我一开始也只希望你不会倒，为了省钱，墙壁都自己糊，自己刷，书与CD也是自己的。
马克思入门导读，百年孤寂，戴墨镜的飞鼠，与好双女人拍拍站。
播放陈小侠、陈山妮、陈明璋与陈生的音乐，转换着心情。
虽然希望不要倒，但还是要做自己。
情况有些客人不高兴，但我就是要在椅子上挂胸罩，在墙上挂卫生棉，把性摊开来。
16世纪的烈纱女巫行动，就是对女人幸运与能力的压制。
知识、音乐、美食、性爱都带给人力量与欢愉。
你就是要让客人离开时，自我感觉良好。
开店半年后，你开始有了现场演唱，起音竟是一狗冰狼枝。
通话接Scum有位不服领检的客人，在警车上吐冰狼枝。
Scum也在警区警员已在取地下卸业。
器材与人力于是办事到女巫店重新开张。
以往的地下音乐从地下室的Scum来到一楼的女巫店，名字也慢慢变成了独立音乐。
张璇第一次在女巫店表演时，只会四个吉他和弦。
陈其真的首唱像是好友谈心的亲密，因为来的都是自己人。
第一次见到黄晓珍，他进来推销自制的录音带。
而那时已是CD普及的90年代后半。
谢宇威则是在对面烧烂门口抽烟，被我发现跟CD上长的人好像，请他来助唱。
当然还有许许多多大家不曾听过，或是曾经有人喜欢，却已经不知道在哪里的名字。
小美人于故事里的坏女巫，夺去小美人于的声音。
女巫店却是要让不同的声音被更多人听到。
即使那声音是质嫩或沙哑的。
在职业坡缩的老龙树下，南部的奥基桑拉着二胡，花脸的原住民也可以用夜市里粗用的投币卡拉OK机，换上一整页。
从手机不服彼的年代走到了现在，用iPad就可以組band，扩好乐团，扩好玩。
对于独立音乐界，我希望你就像老龙树与卡拉OK机一般，不是最新最炫的，但我一直在那里。
还好你已经大了，也不是叛逆的16岁少女。
这几年我忙着带小孩，推广桌上游戏，都是小女巫们陪伴你，你还是如同遗忘开心又健康。
就连先前因为法规面临关店危机，我还没做出反应，就有众多朋友第一时间跳出来守护你。
这让我真气的意识到，你真的有了女巫的魔力，可以自己好好地走下去，或许还可以爱你一万年。
没用完毕，以上就是关于女巫店的故事。
原来的我以为，我们无法轻易定义她的存在，也无法随意放下对她的期待，
只因为女巫店承载了太多我们没有肉身，而只是在脑中想象过的文艺记忆。
不过实际上，她就像龙树一般，从意外的生根发芽，倒长成了一颗餐厅小树。
她接受了自己是一颗不大的龙树，只是餐厅小树，
因为她的树鹰让一些人获得了阴凉，而可以静静坐着的地方。
也在阳光正好的时候，允许大家一起，亲近歌唱。
谢谢你听到这里，我为一起远远地看见了这棵树，也祝福你找到自己的那一棵树。
以上就是本期节目的所有内容。
下一期节目我会聊聊那些从女巫店成长起来的音乐人，请大家敬请期待。
今天的片尾曲来自张璇在2006年发表的第一张个人专辑，
有一个限量版的预购赠品就是今天的这首歌，当时上面写着先给玉京和她的女巫店。
要记得听到最后哦。
也欢迎大家在评论区或者邮箱和我分享你们的感受。
我的邮箱是cccchikaliatgmail.com。
如果你喜欢这期播客，记得订阅，还要分享给你身边的朋友。
小新地华是一档经路生活与生存的播客。
万事不易，希望你滑倒了，也可以放成大哭。
想要加入听邮曲的朋友，也可以在修诺词里面添加小助手的联系方式。
欢迎大家一起来聊天。
最后呢，想要谢谢最近给小新地华答上的朋友。
明亮的夜晚。
Lucky Neko。
Lkiki。
Zuhan Riki。
YQAIAIAI5KAI。
想吃蛮丽哦。
Ripple Yang。
现在除了小宇宙之外，大家也可以上爱发电给我答上。
聚姐，练结想念秀notes。
感谢大家的支持。
我们下次再见啦。
拜拜。
练结想念秀notes。
我的宝贝，宝贝，给你一点甜甜。
让你今夜都好眠。
我的小鬼，小鬼，都懂你的笑脸。
让你喜欢整个世界。
你喜欢整个世界吗。
我喜欢这个世界。
我喜欢你的街面。
我要里面取起你的笑脸。
我们下次见。
我的寶貝 要你知道你最美。
詞曲 李宗盛